And now it's the old scout master.
Hi Clark,
My name is Cameron Smith.
I am a scout master from 51 in the Nesta Hotel
And I had something kind of rare that I wanted to just run by quick.
You see, I'm relatively new as a scout master, but it hasn't taken long since I've become
a scout master that I started to have this dozen urge to grow a beard.
I can't explain it, but it was real.
I had this real urge to grow a beard,
So I gave it some time.
I grew a beard,
And then I go to camp.
I couldn't help but notice that there's a lot of scout masters that were sporting beards.
We go back from camp,
I'm going to council functions here and there
And sure enough, I'm seeing a lot of guys working beards. is beard growing a side effect
being a scout master?
Or is it nearly that bearded men are more prone to being scout masters?
Or is the fact that I am allowing such a goofy question to consume my mind
proof that I am suffering from some sort of rare scout master mental illness?
I'm not sure, but I figured if anybody knew it would have to be Mr
Parker.
So keep up the good work.
I love your podcast and your scout circles are pretty awesome.
Thank you very much,
Cameron. I think he got something there.
It's not a mental illness,
It's called a state of mind.
If you have an answer to any of Cameron's several questions or concerns there,
you can call and leave a message and it might be on a future podcast.
So call 484-734-0002..
484-734-0002..
See if you can give Cameron a hand.
Hey, this is podcast number 189..
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Greene.
Let's take a look at the mailbag.
Got a lot in the mailbag this week.
Bill Daniel wrote in and said this:
Scouts will give you great insight if you listen. once
I had a parent tell me that the patrol leader reacted to my presence
by saying: good, the scout master is here,
He won't let the assistant scout masters tell us what to do.
That made me feel appreciated and even a little vindicated.
Another scout was running for senior patrol leader and he stated
that his goal would be to make patrols more than a place to stand in line.
Now that gave me the message that it took several years to digest.
We had moved down the path to being boy led.
We had a strong troop,
Yet our patrols were simply kind of this administrative label
in a troop organization chart,
What I inherited and blindly accepted.
You know it seemed to be working,
but I knew that it needed to be examined and questioned.
Your podcast has given me much pause about this
and the patrol method.
We've changed from scientifically engineered, adult concocted patrols
that are ones of the scout's own choosing.
I readily accept that my job as scout master is to remove obstacles
and enable scouts to be scouts.
Now my challenge is to get the scouts to move forward
and even so that they notice these obstacles for themselves
and they have the freedom of new thoughts
leading to new actions and new achievements.
Bill, thanks so much for that
And I'm always excited and encouraged to hear
that people are making sense out of all this.
Thanks again, Bill,
Over on Stitchercom, which is a great way to listen to the podcast
if you on any mobile device. Stitchercom
Howard left us this review.
He said the podcast does a great job of providing assistance
to scout masters in particular,
but really anyone who's working as a leader or a volunteer
or the parent of a scout.
Clark explains difficult concepts clearly.
He answers questions from rookie and veteran leaders alike.
He has fascinating stories to tell.
Really,
I've recommended his show to a number of scout leaders
and they thank me for introducing him to it
and all he has to offer.
Wow, Howard, thank you so much.
I really appreciate the kind words there.
Don Mitchell is in Troop 1 in Huntington Beach, California.
He says I love the podcast and the website.
They're great resources.
I often forward items along to the other folks in the troop.
I've been listening to them directly from the website
and I like the links you provide on the show notes.
Anyway, on your end, to make things work a little bit better,
it would be great if I could play the podcast in a new window.
That way I could keep browsing and look at the references
that you refer to or look at a blog entry.
I'm finding this kind of difficult to do right now.
Thanks, and keep up the good work.
Well, John, I've got great news for you.
I've spent some time putting together a new podcast archive
and from here on out, I'm going to publish the podcast.
make sure that they have a very clear way
of opening them up in a new window
so you can browse the website and listen to the podcast
at the same time.
I think I've improved the ability of people
to be able to download past podcasts.
make that a little bit simpler.
So go to scoutmastercgcom. right there
at the top of the page
In the main menu is the podcast archive.
Take a look at that and tell me if that solves
the problem for you.
Hey, John, you're far from alone.
I've had a number of requests over time
to add these features
and I think I got it worked out finally.
So check out the podcast archive and let me know.
John Wiebke is in Zionsville, Indiana with troop 358..
He said thanks again for the inspiration
and knowledge passed on in the podcast
articles and resources.
I'm beside myself finding so much good information
about your experiences in Algonquin Provincial Park
in Ontario, Canada,
because our troop is going to be traveling
there next summer.
Well, John, you're going to really love Algonquin
and I'm glad that you're finding the information
that we've shared about our annual canoe trips
useful. and have a great trip next summer
And make sure to tell us about it.
So before we get started here,
let me remind you that our next scout circle
is Sunday, October 13th, from 9 to 10 pm.
What is scout circle, you ask?
Scout circle is a live video presentation.
We have a guest on and they do their presentation
and then we open up for questions
and you can send a question by email.
And this October scout circle,
the subject is backpacking
And our guest is Joe Jacaruso from gossamergearcom.
Joe's an experienced scouter
who's led a lot of scout backpacking trips,
and the subject is scouts and backpacking.
That's Sunday, October 13th,
from 9 to 10 pm
at scoutsircleorg.
scoutsircleorg,
In this podcast in just a moment,
we're going to talk about what happens
when weeblos visit your troop meeting,
and then we have some e-mail questions to answer
and that's going to take up the rest of the podcast.
so let's get started. shall we
Show master'ship in seven minutes
or less?
So over the next couple of months
you're going to start getting requests
for second-year weeblos then
to come visit your scout troop.
Over the years we've been all over the map
about how to do this. in our troop
We've had very formal presentations
with lots of paperwork and handouts
and PowerPoint, and you know
we've done our best to put the poor parents
that come to visit us to sleep.
So over the next couple of months,
you're going to start getting requests
for the poor parents that come to visit us to sleep.
So
What I've hit on is a method
that I want to share with you
and you may find it effective too
When the weeblos and their parents come to visit.
we have a couple of our scouts
are ready to work with the weeblos
for the entirety of the meeting.
They have a couple of things planned for them.
They get them to participate
in whatever the troop is doing.
They'll play some games
and generally have a good time,
and take the parents over to a separate room
and sit them down
and we have a pretty informal conversation with them.
We let them ask questions about the troop.
You know we introduced the troop adult leadership
at some point early on.
while the committee chairman is talking with the parents,
I will leave the room, go out
and I will find a scout that joined the troop
this past year.
So I get a first year scout-
It doesn't really matter who-
and I ask him. if he has a couple of minutes
to ask me,
I bring him in and I introduce him to the parents
and I say: here's John.
He joined the troop February of last year
and the best way to learn
about the experience for a scout
in our troop is to talk to the scouts.
So you've got about five minutes
to ask John some questions
and sometimes it's a little slow to get started.
so I help them out a little bit.
I ask John a couple of questions from them,
but parents get the idea
and they start asking questions
and they would not necessarily
ask an adult leader.
Well, how do the older scouts treat?
How are you doing with advancement?
Do you enjoy going camping
and what was summer camp like,
and things like that.
So once they're talking with
that first year scout,
I leave the room again
and I find a second year scout
and this process goes on
and each one of them has about five minutes or so
with the parents
who are attending that meeting.
I'll get a scout representative
of X number of years in the troop.
I'll bring them in,
let the parents talk to them for a while-
and you know
I try and listen to some of those questions
and if there are subjects that come up,
we'll expand on those a little bit
once we have a chance.
majority of the time that the parents are going to spend visiting
our troop meeting
they'll be talking to our scouts.
I don't tell the scouts to expect this
and compare them for it in any way.
I just kind of let them go in cold
and
we give them a couple of quick words of explanation
about who these people are that they're talking to,
and a couple of guys have done it several times
now and so they understand
what goes on.
but it works really really well
and it gives people a very good picture
of what goes on in your troop.
now, since we started doing this-
and I guess it's maybe three or four years that we've been doing this-
every time we've done this,
at least one or two of the weeblos
that are visiting to join the troop-
and a lot of times we'd get the whole group,
but I don't think we've ever missed
getting at least one of them.
that's one take on managing the weeblos den visit.
love to hear what you have to say about it,
so make sure you get in touch
and you'll find out how to do that at the end of the podcast.
round the roll,
round the reed
round the roll.
come join my happy song,
find me a letter,
send it by name.
email that is, folks,
and here's an answer to one of your
emails.
so this week we heard from Brian
in centerville, georgia, with troop 400,
and Brian had this to say:
he said: thanks for all your posts.
they always seem right on the point.
as the outdoor activities committee chair,
I've been working with patrols
and the senior patrol leader
encouraging the plan patrol activities.
I found that because of some of the
youth protection rules,
our scouts kind of face this catch 22.
we want them to do these things
independently and doing them on their own,
but apparently we have to have two adults
there, right?
so my question is is: how does 2d leadership
work for patrol activities?
for example, one of our patrollers
wanted to have a video game night
at his home. I was really not
too sure if he would be able to do
that or not without a couple of adult
leaders present. and I'm also curious
as to whether or not these type of plans
should be vetted through the scout master,
or can patrols just make this happen?
while I support the idea
of youth protection, these rules sometimes
seem to hinder opportunities
and frankly, I think things were a lot
easier and simpler in the old days.
well, Brian, the first rule on questions
like this is: we run to the resource,
and the resource for this question
is the guide to safe scouting,
and right there on page one, under the
heading scoutings- barriers to abuse,
you're going to find this:
2d leadership on all outings
is required. we've registered adult
leaders, or one registered adult
leader and a parent of a
participating scout or other adult,
one of whom must be 21 years
of age or older, are required
for all trips and outings.
there are a few instances,
such as patrol activities,
when the presence of adult leaders
is not required and adult
leadership may be limited to
training and guidance of patrol
leadership. with the proper
training, guidance and approval
by the troop leaders,
the patrol can conduct day hikes
and service projects. appropriate
leadership must be present
for all overnight
scouting activities. there's your answer,
Brian. a day or an evening
activity like the video game
night you describe does not
need to adults present,
as long as your patrol
leader has the proper training,
guidance and approval.
but let's be clear about this:
all overnight activities has to
have to deep leadership,
as described in youth protection policies.
all that needs to happen, in my humble
opinion, is to talk with
patrol ears and describe the policy,
ask them how they will
make sure that the policy is followed
and make whatever modifications
you think are required to their plans.
in the example that you gave, a video
night at a scouts home. well, that sounds
great. so
what would a patrol leader need to know
and what training, guidance and approval
should he have before he does this
activity? the simple concept
is that if it's a Boy Scout gathering,
whether it's a patrol or a troop,
whether it's something casual like a video
night at a scouts home or something formal
like camp out, it's our obligation
to keep things safe and appropriate.
I would spend some time with your patrol
and get them to think this through.
they would want to do things like
ask permission of the host parents.
they want to discuss the kind of
activities they would be doing,
how long they would be doing them.
are they going to need any facilities
or food or anything like that?
and then, once they've discussed that
with the host parents, they need to make sure
that they have approval from the troop.
and you know, somebody might want to pick up the phone
and call the host parents just to make sure that
they know that this is going on.
I think it's all really pretty simple
and common sense. it's probably
10 minutes worth of planning and discussion.
you said that you were worried that these
rules sometimes hinder
opportunities and the things were much
easier and simpler in the old days.
but I'm going to disagree with you
if you really want to hinder possibilities.
watch what happens if the scout gets injured
or some kind of inappropriate activity
goes on. now, perhaps in the old days
you know, 99 out of 100
times it was really that simple
and we didn't need any rules.
but the one time that a scout was injured
or abused, it got complicated.
you don't need a whole lot of imagination
to see how something as simple as
the video game night could go south
pretty quickly. so does 10 minutes
of thinking and planning and having those
plans vetted for obvious safety
or propriety concerns make things
all that much difficult?
I don't think so. it's just good common sense,
and folks that don't exercise
that type of common sense can end up
in a real mess on their hands.
youth protection rules are there to do what?
to protect our youth, not to complicate
things or to hinder scouts from
doing what they want to do.
you know the host parents and the adults
who are going to make things like this possible.
you know drivers and things like that.
I think a quick word from the scout master
is a good idea. encourage them
to let the scouts do everything for themselves.
tell them that the scouts are going to be
troubled to ask if they need help.
tell them to observe from a distance.
give them a contact number to call if they have
any questions.
Barb Higgins is in Hurlock, Maryland,
with troop 167.
she said your post about the five
basic patrol fundamentals
was received at a perfect time for us.
we've got a small troop of seven boys,
ages 11 through 14,
and we go camping every month.
so how do we do the patrol system
in such a small troop? we've got two
patrols right now, but it doesn't seem
to work all that well and we know that
it's not right to put everybody together
in one patrol, because then we don't have the patrol method.
I understand what you're saying about the patrol
method. it's a large troop, but with a troop
of seven I just don't see how to make it work.
well, Barb, the answer is
very, very simple. with seven
scouts you have one patrol.
there's no need for multiple patrols at all.
so you don't need a senior patrol
leader or troop officers and that wise.
all you need is a patrol leader and then
everybody in the patrol with only seven boys
is always going to have some kind of
responsibility to do. you can have a patrol
scribe and a patrol quartermaster and
a cook and a fire builder and all that kind of
great stuff and all the scouts will be
pulling in the same direction and they
might want to end up electing a new patrol
leader a little more often than you might
have it done in a troop. they may want to do
that every three or four months.
whatever works for them to achieve the
aims of the patrol method is what
you need to apply. don't think that you
have to have a big formal by the book
troop setup with just a seven
or a dozen scouts. perhaps
that's a goal for them as the troop
grows. but for now
you know they can function very well as one
patrol and they're going to have a great time doing it.
and when they do, their friends are going to
find out and pretty soon you're going to
go beyond seven scouts.
Dave Schmidt is with troop 201
in Pratt Kansas.
he says I am a new scout master
and I trust our scouts to
take home the information that's disseminated
to them at troop meetings and
tell their parents about it. but I understand
that sometimes it doesn't always work that
way. so I was thinking of
some kind of newsletter or something like that,
but I'm no good at that sort of thing.
can you suggest a template
or a website that I could use.
Dave, you don't need a template,
you don't need a website. what you need as a scout
to publish your newsletter right. so at
the next troop meeting, go to the scouts, say
I think it would be useful for us to
have a little one page newsletter. who would like
to publish it? and you're going to find that
one of your scouts is going to be pretty excited about
doing that. and you know, when it comes to computers
and publishing and printing and things like that,
you know they know a whole lot more than we
do. to begin with this next question,
I'm withholding the personal information
at the sender's request.
the question says this: tonight was a big night.
we had our senior patrol leader election,
the reconfiguration of patrols and
patrol leader elections. the last podcast
could not have been more timely. you made
it clear to me that this is
a process for the scouts.
we let them decide about patrols
and we shouldn't be stepping
into, configure patrols or point youth leaders.
now I have my in my mind
what a good configuration of patrols
would be, but I kept my mouth shut,
confident that my role as scout master
was to sit back and observe
our newly elected senior patrol leader
circled up with the senior scouts
and made up the patrols. they did
what a lot of adults would do:
they balanced numbers and ranks and ages
and separated the boys who hadn't gotten along
in the past. now they did all this
while I was doing something else, so I
didn't really see what they were up to.
when I looked at the result, I saw some
really disappointed faces where
friendships had been separated, and I
think some of our older scouts
felt like they had been taken down a peg
or two by being assigned to a patrol
with the youngest scouts. I asked the senior
patrol leader if they let the scouts
have their choice of patrol
or whether they did all the
arranging. they said that they
had worked it out themselves and they
really hadn't asked the scouts.
I was hesitant to intervene any further,
so I just nodded my head and kept my
mouth shut. so my question is this:
what do you do when the youth leaders
do something that you say adults shouldn't do?
if I step in and I
vetoed the new patrol assignments,
it would undermine and embarrass the new senior
patrol leader, but if I don't step in,
it looks like there's going to be some unhappy scouts.
well, first and foremost,
good idea for nodding your head
and keeping your mouth shut.
you get a medal for that
in that kind of a situation.
I congratulate you for your extraordinary
self control and forethought.
I would say that right now you've got
one of the best opportunities to
work the patrol method and to help
develop your youth leadership.
before the next meeting, sit down
with your senior patrol leader
and ask him to observe carefully during
that meeting and look at the way
the patrols are working and see how well
the choices that he made for the scouts are being
accepted. do your own observation
and keep your own notes during the meeting
and then sit down with the senior
patrol leader again and ask him if he
saw the same things that you did.
maybe you saw a scout leave his patrol
and go hang out with his friend
and the other patrol, or something like that.
if there's a problem with the choices
that the senior patrol leader made and making
up the patrols, it's going to be pretty apparent
and you have the perfect opportunity
to help him see through these things
and maybe see where he went wrong
and you can ask him a lot of questions
about it. you know you decided
who would be in what patrol. do you think
it might be a better idea to let the
scouts make those decisions.
ask him how he would feel if somebody
decided to split up the troop
and he and his friends ended up in
separate troops. I think it's a great
opportunity and, honestly, I love it.
when this type of stuff happens in my own troop.
it gives me the chance to work with
my youth leaders and ask questions that hopefully
lead them to a point of discovery
and they figure out how to fix things.
now, if you decide to follow that advice,
I'd love to hear how it goes. so keep in touch.
you can get in touch with me if you have a question,
and you're going to find out how to do that
in just a moment.
well, thanks so much
for listening to this edition
of the scout master podcast.
here's how to stay in touch.
read the scout master blog
at scoutmastercom.
you can also get the scout master podcast
on iTunes,
and you can access the podcast
on your mobile device through Stitcher
smart radio.
get details about how to do that at
stitchercom.
you can experience the wonders of
scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media.
you can follow us at scoutmaster blog
on Facebook.
we tweet at scoutmastercg,
at scoutmastercg on Twitter
and you can watch us at scoutmastercg
on YouTube. and for admittance to the
exclusive scoutmastercg circle,
look for us on Google plus.
if social media doesn't do it for you,
well, that's okay,
you can email me.
zoom in to the late 90s and email me,
Clark Greene, with your comments and questions
at Clark at scoutmastercgcom.
that's C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom.
and now
I disclaim.
that's right. the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America, nor are they
endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
hey, it's just some guy with a microphone
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and maybe have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun, here is
our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Bowl. Sir Robert,
good luck to you and group camping
why? thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone.